laurent jacobellis bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
au micro tout à l'heure de katia
technique il y avait la conseillère de
paris la france insoumise danielle
simonnet qui disait avec cette loi on
glisse vers une société de surveillance
systématiser et en bascule vers un
régime autoritaire qu'est ce que vous
lui répondait bonjour avait écouté je
lui réponds que je ne crois pas que en
l'état ce soit toujours le cas bien sûr
il faut toujours faire attention et
faire attention que ces lois qui sont
censées régir la sécurité ne s'applique
pas de manière trop intrusive dans la
vie privée des gens honnêtes
en revanche est essentiel de protéger
nos policiers et je ne comprends pas ce
qui gêne madame simonet dans le fait
qu'on interdise de livrer à la vindicte
publique
le visage de policiers est probablement
parce que avec beaucoup d'autres
gauchistes et gens d'extrême gauche elle
a organisé l'odieuse mise en scène
billère qui a utilisé de pauvres gens
des migrants pour faire la promotion de
son message politique son message
politique qui est celui de la france a
soumis lizin qui est mort au fric et
ouvrons grand les frontières aux
migrants il ya quelques jours un
journaliste qui a reçu des coups et sans
images on n'aurait pas vu également
certaines vidéos de policiers de fait
inacceptable comme le dit le ministre de
l'intérieur lui-même d'ailleurs et une
ouverture d'une enquête de la part du
parquet de paris concernant le croche
pied d'un d'un policier sur un grand oui
mais nous verrons bien ce que dira
l'enquète moi vous savez je suis
toujours gêné quand on considère que les
policiers sont présumés coupables
pour moi ils sont présumés innocents on
peut supposer que quand ils utilisent à
force c'est parce qu'ils en ont besoin
et on attendra les résultats de l'
enquête avant de condamner
je suis très surpris que le ministre de
l'intérieur soit plus prompte à
diligenter des enquêtes sur des
policiers qui font leur travail plutôt
que sur les centaines de migrants
illégaux qui était la face à la police
et qui n'ont pas été arrêtés et qui
n'ont pas été reconduits à la frontière
oui il y avait des hors la loi il y
avait place de la république
mais c'était pas les forces de l'ordre
une fois encore monsieur d'arman a
montré son vrai visage il avoue
parler comme comme charles pasqua et au
final c'est le sosie de monsieur
castaner il se couche devant les
rodomontades de l'extrême gauche et il
lâche en plein milieu du guet les forces
de police attendons de voir ce que
donnera l'enquêté
mais très sincèrement hier les forces de
l'ordre se redonner les conclusions qui
vont être livrés d'ici à 48 heures selon
selon gérald darmanin jean castex
annonce à l'instant qu'il va saisir
lui-même le conseil constitutionnel
votre réaction
très bien le constitution de conseil
constitutionnel est là pour faire en
sorte que les lois qui sont votées sont
conformes à la constitution c'est vrai
qu'on a vu un certain nombre de lois mal
ficelé par ce gouvernement bâclée et
effectivement puisqu'il s'agit là de
protéger les policiers
il ne faut pas bâcler la loi donc on
verra bien ce que ça donne mais une fois
encore je suis très surpris que monsieur
castex suivent la direction indiquée par
l'extrême gauche
en regardant de près ce qui se passe
avec les actes des policiers il faut le
faire bien sûr mais qu'il oublie que
dans la capitale de la france hier un
bidonville a été organisée en quelques
heures par des associations et des
militants d'extrême-gauche utilisant la
faiblesse humaine des migrants la vraie
question que cela pose c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui le droit d'asile et des
tournées en france
comment on en est arrivé à ce que nos
frontières soient grandes ouvertes à
toute la misère du monde et pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à renvoyer chez eux des
gens qui sont illégalement sur le sol
français
je pense qu'il faut pas détourner le
débat de l'essentiel je me permets de
revenir sur la loi sécuritaire global
marine le pen a déclaré il ya quelques
jours que ce texte ne mérite ni aux
prunes ne mérite ni excès d'eau preuve
ni excès d'honneur est ce que c'est une
façon habile de dire que le rn approuve
ce projet de loi non c'est une manière
de dire que sous le titre sécurité
globale on se retrouve avec une
proposition de loi des propositions de
loi bien loin de la réalité bien loin de
ce que nécessite l'état de la france
libre est aujourd'hui à l'ensauvagement
au terrorisme et très honnêtement tout
cela n'est pas à la hauteur et puis pour
être globale ces lois cette loi devrait
prendre aussi en considération l'aspect
pénal l'aspect judiciaire
hier on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui de
nombreuses lois ne sont pas appliquées à
cause du laxisme de la justice que des
voyous traînent dans les rues parce
qu'il n'ya pas assez de places de prison
et tout cela n'est pas traitée dans ce
projet sécurité globale alors monsieur
dupont moretti était aux abonnés absents
l'a peu vu sur ce sujet probablement
parce qu'il est plus enclin à vider les
prisons qui allait remplir mais si
derrière tout acte de la police il y a
remise en cause de la police par le
ministère de l'intérieur puis remise en
cause de la peine par la justice eh bien
on n'arrivera à rien à un moment où la
france subit une envolée des vols des
agressions et la menace terroriste
dernière question sur
c'est ce projet de loi avec notamment
les éléments perçus comme l'atteinte à
la liberté de la presse un nouveau
schéma du maintien de l'ordre qui impose
aux journalistes de se disperser dès que
l'ordre est donné par les policiers de
partir gérald darmanin a également
déclaré il ya quelques jours que les
journalistes devaient se rapprocher de
la préfecture pour couvrir une
manifestation
les récentes images de journalistes
brutalisés ce qui est un problème
fondamental dans la vision du
gouvernement face au droit d'informer
oui je pense qu'on peut lire là pour le
coup je pense qu'il faut laisser les
journalistes faire leur métier que il
faille protéger les policiers c'est une
chose mais il faut aussi protéger la
liberté de la presse
on voit bien que dans la gestion des
crises le gouvernement est mal à l'aise
avec la vérité avec la démocratie on l'a
vu dans la question sanitaire où il ne
prenait pas en considération les avis de
l'opposition et où il traitait mal le
parlement on l'a vu lors de la crise des
gilets jaunes lors des manifestations
d'infirmières c'est vrai que c'est une
tentation autocratique de ce
gouvernement et singulièrement
d'ailleurs du président de la république
qui gouverne seul qui se passe de la vie
de ses ministres et du parlement c'est
vraiment une tentation
donc il faut être très vigilant merci à
laurent jacobellis d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
porte parole du rassemblement national